Nếu như gánh môi nhất được công bố, tui chiến dịch quần sự quay ổn mĩ bảy strend
nhằm vào viên ràn. Chị dịch có sự thăm ra của mấy bảy chứ đầu em bảy em
bảy hài hài. Mấy bảy nếp bóc bảy hài sprit, đưa lượng hình chình
to mà ốc. Lần đầu tiên các bảy bảy hương người lại tất công một châu,
một phòng thương mấy bảy hương người lại xa hẹp của viên ràn.
Đã được lượng tắc nghiệm của quần đường mĩ sử dục để tất công viên ràn.
Chỉ dịch eu xoang đặt tên là sương từ gầm, con mĩ còn lạ chỉ dịch.
Gức thinh hậu dút rồi. Trốn thông nhận nước i Ràn xanh gi lạnh tủ tui
khao, arjettle ra, alí, khả nề, cùng nhiều tương linh cấp cao trong được lượng bố chã của
nước này đã thịt mà. Mỗi ra ích nhất ai chăm mười khách đã thịt mà.
Bà hư bẩy chăm người bị thương, chăm các cuộc tấn công của mĩ chủi şoán vào i ràn.
Dương trường hậu ở thành phố mi Náp của i Ràn, nơi chung tên lửa chung cuộc tấn công của i
và đúng chăm sóng như thế mà phần lớn là các nước xin.
Cái gì đó, nó có thể nhìn thấy những người anh ngại.
Thế lớp thấy biết sự thật.
Đây là sức tạo qua của một lúc kẻ.
Hãy lúc kẻ bây giờ nè.
És rồi anh hôm nay vẫn thực hiện các tật công mối nhằm vào y ra.
Đi đáp trạng, lượng lượng vệ bình kinh mạo hồi giáo iran truyền bố,
sẽ sương tiến hành cho sự tình công vữ dội nhất trong lịch sử.
Nhằm vào Isuan và Mi.
Đây là đất hiện sảo lợ tình công vữ vô lượng ở lịch tiến trong chính sĩnh mang tên lời hữu trên thật bố.
Phong hằng chăm tên lượng và tiếp bị bài không người lại URV,
nhằm vào lắng thổ Isuan và hãy thống cân cửa quân sự của Mi ở khách của vực Trung Đông.
Lợ tình công mối nhất nhằm vào chút sở bộ tổng thông yêu Isuan
và hố phó khởp công nghệ quân sự lưỡng ở tên à viết.
Các khi tại 2 quân khá của Mi cũng nằm trong tập bán của Tiến lợ và URV,
trong các cuộc tấn công đăng dễ ra.
Rồi chức quân sự Isuan khẩm lịch,
chính sĩnh đắp trả chúng lại Mi và Isuan sẽ tiếp tục mà không có sự giảnh đoạn.
Iran đã thành lập một hộ đồng lâm thời,
hồn tổng thống mà suốt Pé zes kiaan.
Chỉ ngán toàn tôi cao,
cùng một tình viên hộ đồng giá hộ,
để điều hành đến nước sau khi lãnh tụi tôi cao Ali sau mà nè kịt mà.